juveniles in federal custody will no
longer be subject to solitary
confinement which is great news if
you're one of the 26 youngsters in the
federal prison
see if you're under 18 there are two
paths into the federal penal system
committing a felony on tribal lands or
in Washington DC but as of 2013 there
were around 35,000 use held in state
juvenile detention facilities and a 2003
study found that more than 15% of them
have been in solitary their prisoners
are confined in a small cell alone for
at least 22 hours a day with minimal
human contact psychological effects of
isolation begin to appear after three
days and the UN says that more than 15
days is a form of torture here in the US
solitary can last for decades
21 states prohibit the use of solitary
confinement for juveniles while others
place restrictions on how it can be used
but 10 don't have any limits for
juveniles oh and the roughly 1,000
juveniles held in adult prisons can be
sent to solitary under the same rules as
adult inmates even though they're under
18 younger people are particularly
vulnerable to the psychological effects
of solitary even prisoners who aren't
mentally ill are likely to experience
some form of mental illness afterwards
over half the miners who killed
themselves in juvenile detention did so
while in isolation
you